the Today's Show has a report about the
hot new consumer product on the market
that everybody is raving about
apparently I got a
Stanley the Stanley quencher Cup that is
sold in over a hundred different colors
the $45 reusable bottles are flying off
shelves the hash Stanley Cup racking up
6.7 billion views on Tik Tok with videos
of fans collecting them decorating them
naming them even camping out for them so
it's almost 3 in the morning people
lining up overnight at Starbucks and
Target stores to snag a limited edition
version so this is the New Sensation
it's an insulated cup I mean that's all
it is there it's an insul there are
millions of insulated cups on the market
they're all the same the Stanley Cup is
not functionally different from any
other insulated cup but this is the one
that everybody wants right now and why
do they want it they don't know they
they uh they they couldn't tell you but
they'll camp out overnight for it
they'll camp out overnight for a cup